some parts of Houston could face more
flooding this morning ten days after
Harvey first made landfall debris from
the storm lines streets throughout the
city at least 46 people are confirmed
dead about 6800 homes were destroyed and
nearly 87,000 damaged Texas governor
Greg Abbott says the financial cost of
Harvey could be up to 180 billion
dollars mandatory evacuation orders are
in place for people who live near to
swollen reservoirs in West Houston
Michelle Miller is along the Barker
reservoir Michelle good morning good
morning this corporate Park this entire
neighborhood we're told did not flood
during the hurricane it is under water
now as a result of those two reservoir
releases but a necessary evil officials
say to save many more neighborhoods
downstream and water isn't the only
hazard left behind in Harvey's wake more
than a week after Harvey made its US
landfall communities across Houston and
East Texas are racing to get a handle on
the storms devastation National
Guardsmen airlifted in bottled water to
Beaumont where flooding overwhelmed the
city's pumping station knocking out
running water for days in Crosby
evacuated residents surrounding the
Arkham a chemical plant were allowed
home after officials successfully
ignited six trailers burning off any
remaining flammable chemicals
evacuations are still being ordered in
Houston about 300 people were forced
from their homes in western stretches of
that city on Sunday the police came
knocked on my door and said you have 10
minutes to get out and there was a canoe
waiting Houston Mayor Sylvester Turner
says the evacuations were necessary to
ensure the safety of first responders on
Sundays Face the Nation he said nature
wasn't only to blame for flooding in the
area in West Houston those homes didn't
flood because of the rainfall they are
flooding because of the release of water
from the reservoir it's just running to
cotton picking hard Richard long is with
the US Army Corps of Engineers
he says intentionally releasing water
from the reservoirs avoided a much
larger catastrophe a prod
just built to handle a certain size
event and if you get an event bigger
than that something's got to give and we
had to make these releases to ensure the
integrity of our project when you look
out and you see all of these homes
flooded he's visited your office yes
what do you feel it hurts
it really does these are my friends and
neighbors long says his team will start
to reduce the flow of those releases
very soon but those releases will
continue through November Jeff Michelle
thank you very much